Okay.
This week we're going to,
we're going to continue in our discussion about the,
uh,
about the immune system,
but talk about sort of engineering the immune system,
how to,
how to produce immunity in individuals.
And we're going to do that by,
uh,
by talking about some examples,
some historical examples,
uh,
in the,
sort of technology of vaccine development.
And what I hope to do over the course of
this lecture and the lecture on Thursday is,
um,
is a complete,
what's described on this outline slide here.
First using a couple of examples that have turned out to be a very important one
is the example of smallpox.
And the second is the example of,
of polio.
Talk about how vaccines were developed in these particular,
uh,
in these particular situations and how the development of the biology is coupled
with,
uh,
delivering this through populations and how,
how these sort of intricately woven together.
It's not enough to understand the biology of how to create,
um,
to create a vaccine if you can't make enough of the vaccine or deliver it to
people in ways that it's useful.
And so we'll talk about how that,
how that happened in the exam,
using the examples of smallpox and polio.
And that will bring us to a general discussion of sort of the tools that are
available now for vaccine development,
which we'll talk about on,
um,
on,
uh,
Thursday.
So,
uh,
I don't have to say too much about why vaccines are important.
Um,
you know about this.
Uh,
and this is a slide that I showed you.
The graph is something I showed you on the first day of class that over the last
hundred years in particular,
uh,
but what's shown on this slide is over the last 300 years,
life expectancy for,
uh,
for humans has increased dramatically.
And one of the reasons,
uh,
that's most responsible for that is that is that humans aren't dying at as young
an age from infectious diseases as they did three or 400 years ago.
And there are many reasons for this,
uh,
our success in eliminating in infectious diseases as causes of death in the
developed world.
And you know,
what those reasons are.
One is is that doctors started washing their hands in between when they saw
patients and that had a remarkable effect on reducing transmission of infectious
diseases in doctor's offices in hospitals.
Another is that we learned a lot of things about engineering,
of,
of uh,
public,
um,
systems like water supply,
separating our water supply from sewage and learning how to do wastewater
treatment was a really important part of reducing infectious diseases.
But vaccines,
uh,
at particularly in the last hundred years,
vaccines have been one of the most important elements in,
in our progress.
And uh,
and so what this slide just reminds you of how much progress we've made also
shows you something about the challenge of it because we are susceptible to
attack from lots of different kinds of microorganisms.
So not just the spectrum of viruses,
but there's viruses and bacteria and parasites and other microorganisms that can
cause disease.
And so this slide just illustrates that in as simple way,
the,
the range of different kinds of organisms that your immune system is trying to,
uh,
whoops,
wait a minute.
I've lost control of,
I'm not saying,
oh,
there it is.
It's not showing up on the screen for some reason.
Um,
um,
that this shows the range of morphologies of microorganisms that your immune
system has to potentially encounter from complex organisms like the syphilis
pathogen here.
Uh,
a virus.
This is a false colored image of a virus,
very tiny,
not shown to scale here.
And,
and,
uh,
bacteria like Salmonella and staphylococcus.
So these,
these organisms like this are abundant in the world around us,
in our immune system,
prevents us from getting sick most of the time.
So what is a vaccine?
A vaccine is a prepared,
it's a preparation that's prepared in some way and we're going to talk about how
they're prepared,
but it's a preparation that is intended to stimulate your immune system.
And so what that really means,
you know,
from last week's lecture,
is that the vaccine stimulates these particular cells in your immune system,
uh,
to give you immunity.
And we're usually talking about adaptive immunity here.
So either it stimulates the production of and differentiation of B cells to
produce a specific antibody that can neutralize the virus or,
or stimulates the production of cytotoxic t cells that can kill infected cells
within your body.
But in,
in any event,
the vaccine is intended to stimulate the immune system to produce an effect,
a response,
either antibodies or specific cells that can combat,
uh,
spread of the microorganism through your,
through your body.
And usually it's done by taking all or parts of the infectious agent and showing
them to your immune system in some way.
And so we talked very briefly last time about this business of antigen
presentation,
how your immune system,
one of the things that it does especially well is recognize what's part of you
and what's not part of you.
It can separate between what's part of yourself and what's foreign.
And it does that by presenting,
by recognizing antigens that are presented in the context of the major
histocompatibility complex MHC.
And so a vaccine is designed in order to engage that biology in order to provide
antigens that will stimulate specifically your immune system.
And usually it involves pieces of the infectious agent itself,
uh,
to,
to cause that engagement.
So that's what a vaccine is in vaccination is the process of taking that vaccine
that you've developed and giving it to people,
uh,
either individual people or groups of people or as we'll talk about today,
people all over the world.
Uh,
and so that's a very different thing,
right?
It designing something that works in a particular individual and designing
something that can be used in people all over the world involve different sorts
of,
uh,
accomplishments.
Well,
we've all had some experience with vaccines.
You can't go to school in this country and in many countries until you've had
your,
your prescribed set of vaccinations.
And so there are already a very safe,
very effective vaccines available for many infectious diseases.
And there's a,
there's a partial list of that shown here,
uh,
starting the top of the list with smallpox.
And that's what we're going to spend most of the time talking about today.
But there are vaccines for rabies,
for typhoid diptheria.
Most recently,
um,
uh,
or more recently,
there was a vaccine for Varicella,
which you know,
is chicken pox.
Uh,
that was developed in the last 10 years and now,
so there's probably a number of people in this room.
So when I first started teaching this class 20 years ago,
uh,
everybody in the room had had chickenpox right?
Now,
are there people here that have not had chicken pox?
Right?
Because you had the vaccine,
uh,
presumably.
And so you didn't get the disease.
And,
um,
so this is,
uh,
this is a substantial change in the,
in the interaction of a micro organism with a population,
right?
A lot of us didn't get sick from it now,
and we've got sick from it before.
You also know that there's some vaccines that are not yet available for diseases
that we would very much like to prevent.
Um,
HIV infection and AIDS is a,
the one that comes first to mind and is responsible for on this slide.
I think this is data from a few years ago,
um,
uh,
700,000 deaths per year.
That number is undoubtedly higher,
uh,
than now.
AIDS is a tremendous problem,
deaths from HIV,
infection and age,
a tremendous problem in Africa and other parts of the world.
Uh,
but there are other diseases that are numerically even more important.
The whole,
uh,
category of diarrheal diseases caused by viruses called enteroviruses,
where,
uh,
they,
it infects your gut,
your guts,
unable to function in the normal way.
And so you get severe diarrhea,
you can become dehydrated and die just as a result of the loss of a water there
because of your body's natural response to the infection.
And that causes five to 10 million deaths per year.
And children are particularly susceptible to these children get diseases from a
class of viruses called Rhoda viruses for which we have no vaccine and,
and um,
and uh,
so no way to protect them.
Malaria causes a million deaths per year.
And schistosomiasis,
which is a parasitic disease,
uh,
is,
unfortunately,
uh,
a common cause of death in the world.
And so these are,
these are,
uh,
these are situations where we would very much like to produce a vaccine,
but we can't yet.
And the question is why,
why is it difficult in some cases to produce a vaccine when we've been
successful in so many others?
And so one of the points I want to make here on this slide is that this is a
very disease specific thing.
Learning how to turn on your immune system to protect you from a specific
pathogen turns out to be very particular to that pathogen.
And that shouldn't be too surprising given what we talked about last week.
That your immune system,
the adaptive immune system in particular,
uh,
responds to individual antigens differently.
Just to think about,
um,
what's most important in the,
in the u s of the top five reported infections in the u s and this is again from
a few years ago,
but I'm fairly sure that the numbers been changed.
Three of the top five infectious diseases or the infectious disease most
commonly reported in the u s are sexually transmitted diseases,
chlamydia,
gonorrhea and HIV infection.
A,
none of these do we have,
do we have,
uh,
vaccines for,
and it's turned out that sexually transmitted diseases for a variety of reasons.
We'll come back to later are a particularly difficult to develop a vaccines,
uh,
for.
And uh,
we'll,
we'll talk about why that's been the case as we go through.
And this just to just,
uh,
is another list.
I mainly wanted you to have it in your notes of,
of diseases that are important around the world for which there are very active,
uh,
programs to develop either vaccines or more effective vaccines.
Uh,
you know that there is a vaccine for hepatitis B for example,
which is on this list and you've all been vaccinated.
I would guess for Hepatitis B,
it's the where you have to get three shots over a period of,
of six months.
And so you have to remember to go back,
you get it first,
you get a first shot,
you have to remember to go back after a month and get a second shot.
You have to go back after six months and get a third shot.
And then they test you to make sure that you have adequate protection.
And some people need an additional shot after that.
And so that's an effective vaccine,
but it's only an effective vaccine in the context where you have people who can
go to the doctor's office or to a,
or to a,
a,
an urgent care or some kind of medical facility three times reliably at a
specified period of time.
And that's not possible in all parts of the world.
Not Everybody has that opportunity to interact with,
uh,
with medical professionals that often.
And so there's a lot of interest not just in developing vaccines for diseases
that we don't have vaccines for,
but for delivering vaccines that are more effective.
For example,
what if you could make a hepatitis vaccine that was good in one shot instead of
three shots or vaccines that could be transported more easily?
The hepatitis vaccine that we get is not stable in less.
It's refrigerated,
it's in solution,
it's refrigerated,
and it's very difficult to transport refrigerated vaccines to all the remote
parts of the world where you would like to trans port them.
And so that very practical consideration turns out to be important in how we use
vaccines in real populations.
So if you could make a hepatitis B vaccine that didn't require a shot or that
didn't require refrigeration,
that would be a tremendous advance and spreading that vaccine,
uh,
through the world.
So that's another example of the difference between a vaccine that works and a
vaccination that works,
right?
A vaccine might work if the person is there and you can interact with them.
A vaccination for it to work around the world has to be inexpensive,
transportable,
possible to use without advanced medical,
uh,
personnel and those kinds of things.
Okay,
so let's talk about the example of smallpox,
which is one of the world's great successes in,
um,
in,
uh,
the battle against infectious diseases.
And just to say a little bit about smallpox,
because unlike chicken pox,
which if you haven't had,
you've probably seen a case of it.
None of us here have seen a case of smallpox.
It hasn't,
it hasn't existed in the world for many decades now,
but smallpox was at one time,
one of the most frightening,
um,
diseases on the planet.
It's a devastating,
frequently fatal infectious disease.
If smallpox occurred in your community,
about 30% of the people that acquire the disease would die from it.
The other 70% could be a disabled or permanently disfigured as a result of the
disease.
It's an infectious disease.
It is spread through the air.
And so it first infects you because you breathe in.
Uh,
some of the infectious agent smallpox is a virus called very ola.
It's a virus that contains DNA,
the name of the viruses,
very ola.
It's part of a family of viruses.
And we'll talk about it at least one other member of that family of viruses as
we go through here.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it can,
it can be acquired in the air from patients that are from,
from other individuals that are infected.
You breathe it in,
it infects the cells of your respiratory tract and the virus begins to reproduce
and then it spreads throughout your body.
And so during the first period after you come in contact with the disease,
you have,
uh,
an incubation period where you get sort of the kind of symptoms that we
associate with lots of kinds of viral infections that we con that we contract
through our respiratory system.
You might have a fever,
malaise,
which is just that feeling that you don't want to get out of bed and go to
class.
And you might have that commonly,
but,
but even more severe than normal aches and a rash.
And this is what's characteristic of smallpox is that as the virus spreads
through your body,
it particularly,
it particularly affects cells of your skin.
And so you get a rash or redness of the skin,
and then you would recover for a while that that initial phase of the illness
would disappear.
Your fever,
Mike go down,
you might appear to be normal.
And then you start to get lesions on your skin that are very characteristic of
smallpox.
And they started as what it called vesicular lesions,
or like blisters where they're filled with a fluid and they evolve to become
very dense hard.
Uh,
or pustular legions,
which are filled with what turns out to be a tissue debris.
It's really just the result of the virus dividing within sales of your skin and
producing a lot of dead cells.
And so that debris,
it fills up a little spot that would feel,
um,
according to reports,
cause again,
we don't see it now.
Um,
it feels like a little pellet underneath your skin and this fluid eventually
starts to leak out.
And the,
those,
uh,
those lesions would heal.
But,
but they leave scars in most cases because these are very deep lesions that go
not just on the surface of your skin like a blister would,
but down into the dermis or deeper layers of the skin as well.
In fact,
certain areas of the skin would be impacted.
Most,
uh,
most are dramatically the face and the chest,
the arms.
But uh,
but,
um,
more distal parts of the arms,
like the palms of your hands.
And so you can imagine that even in it's with all of this activity on your skin,
even at its most,
uh,
um,
least serious level.
It's a terrible disease.
I'll show you a picture in just a moment.
Um,
but in some cases that progression of the disease would start to affect other
organs in addition to your skin and,
uh,
and your body would become overwhelmed with the infection and eventually die.
And as I mentioned before,
death would occur in 20 to 30% of the cases that got the most severe form of
smallpox.
And so if this was a disease that entered your community,
you could have expected,
uh,
several centuries ago that at the end of this sweep of the disease,
through your community,
a one in four or one or five of your neighbors would,
would die from the disease.
And that's has,
that's a dramatic effect on communities.
Well,
um,
smallpox affected world history.
It's,
um,
just as just as HIV infection is affecting world history now.
Smallpox affected world history hundreds of years ago,
and it was a disease disease that was common in Europe,
but not common in the Americas until,
until the Americans were colonized.
And so there are famous,
uh,
reports of how the Aztecs,
that whole civilization was devastated by smallpox.
And that disease was brought to them by the Spanish when they came,
uh,
to these continents in the 16th century.
And,
uh,
the Spanish,
a much smaller group of people was able to overtake the Aztec civilization very
well established,
uh,
because that,
that a group of people was devastated by the disease.
Um,
and um,
uh,
they were weakened as a result.
And so the Spaniards,
even in fewer numbers,
we're able to,
we're able to conquer.
So these are just some pictures to show you what the,
what the smallpox lesions look like on the face of a child and then distributed
over the whole body of an adult.
And,
um,
and to give you some better idea of what kind of a disease this was.
So the process of,
uh,
of developing a vaccine occurred over a long period of time.
In fact,
there's,
there's evidence that even thousands of years ago,
um,
uh,
Indian and Chinese healers,
we're using a form of something that we would recognize as vaccination.
And they did this by taking,
they recognize that somehow if you had a mild exposure to the disease,
your body could then develop protection against more severe forms of the
disease.
And so the older way,
the more ancient way of exposing you to disease was in the case of smallpox to
take,
um,
pieces of tissue from somebody that was infected.
And usually it was one of the,
the scabs that formed as a result of these skin lesions.
And to grind up that scab somehow and expose it to somebody who you wanted to
protect from the disease.
And the way that that Indian healers did this was by putting pieces of this in
your nose or a or injecting it under your skin.
And um,
and there was a,
a,
um,
a feeling that this could protect you against the disease.
And it turns out that,
um,
that there is,
we now know what the scientific basis of that is and involves activation of your
immune system.
And it Wa was a practice that was not broadly used until somebody really studied
it systematically.
And that person who really studied it systematically and is given credit for
developing the first vaccine is a Scottish physician named Edward Jenner.
And he started with a similar,
uh,
with,
with a similar but different observation.
And that was that,
uh,
cows get a disease that's very similar to smallpox.
We know now that it's caused by a related virus,
uh,
called,
Vac Sinia.
Remember the virus that causes that causes smallpox is called Very Ola,
but very yola,
which causes smallpox in humans and Vaccine Ia,
which causes a disease called cow pox in cattle turn out to be,
we now know viruses that are molecularly very similar.
Um,
what was known at that time was that there was a disease in people and that was
a different disease in cows.
And,
and they looked the same some way.
And Jenner made the observation that others had made that people that were
around cows a lot tended not to get smallpox.
And in particular dairy maids whose responsibility was to milk cows.
And so they had a very intimate relationship with cattle,
uh,
often,
didn't get disease and sometimes they developed a mild form of the disease.
They would get lesions on their hands,
for example,
the part of their body that was really in close contact with the cows.
And,
um,
and,
and he hypothesized that they were getting the disease in cows,
which the disease from cows that caused a milder disease than smallpox and that
protected them from getting the more severe forms of smallpox later.
Well,
I mentioned that this was just sort of a more modern,
uh,
observation of one that hadn't bay then made in the past.
This process,
I said this ancient process of taking scabs from patients and introducing them
to people you wanted to protect was called variolation.
Um,
and um,
and Jenner was making a,
another observation that might be useful that way.
Uh,
there were other individuals that were making this observation at that time.
In addition to gender,
there was a farmer named Benjamin Justi who,
uh,
who,
who recognize that farmers being in contact with cows didn't,
uh,
didn't get a disease as often as non farmers did.
And so he intentionally inoculated his wife and two children,
uh,
with,
with fluid that he got from one of his sick cows.
All right.
So he took fluid from a cowpox legion on a county into his children and his wife
reasoning that this would protect them from disease even though they didn't have
as much contact with cows as farmers did.
And he was right.
They got immunity and we're protected from smallpox when it affected their
community.
Gender did this in a much more systematic way.
He used not just his family,
but he used whole populations of people and he produced a,
a fluid from a cow pox lesions.
So these were these lesions,
these skin lesions on cows.
He took this pustular fluid that was produced at this very specific phase of the
disease,
um,
and he,
uh,
and he developed a way for giving that to people.
So,
vaccination,
the word vaccination comes from this event.
Vodka is the,
uh,
I'm sure there's a Latin scholar in here that will correct my pronunciation,
but vodka is the,
uh,
is the Latin word for cow vaccination from cows.
And that's where the first vaccine came from.
Um,
and uh,
and,
and Jenner,
because he was a trained position because he knew something about the scientific
method,
did something that these more ancient healers had not done in the past,
was that he wrote down what he did and he kept track of how many people he gave
the vaccines to.
And then he kept track of what would happen to those people when a smallpox
infection occurred in their community.
And as a result of writing it down and keeping track,
he produced a very clear record,
uh,
and scientific evidence that using this procedure could protect a population of
people,
uh,
from the disease.
So,
um,
so that was the start of,
of the modern practice of vaccination.
There were problems with Jenner's approach and you can imagine what some of
those problems are.
Uh,
one is that,
um,
you got to get the,
you got to get the vaccine from cows,
so you've got to have an infected,
infected cow in order to produce the vaccine.
And so it's awkward to have to wait for a cow to get infected before you can
vaccinate a population.
And what if you're talking about a group of people that don't have any cows in
their vicinity,
let alone is sick cow.
How do you get the vaccine to them?
Well,
that problem was partly solved by saying,
well,
if I,
if I'm,
if I'm giving the inoculation to one person and they develop a lesion locally
and that's what would happen when you would take the fluid from the cow and you
would,
you would,
you would inject it underneath the skin of a,
of a person you wanted to protect.
Then at that site where you injected it,
you would get a lesion that looked like a smallpox or cow pox lesion.
And then we go through these same phases that I described before and it would,
uh,
it would you get a clear blister like region,
it would turn pustular you develop a scab as it healed and then it would,
and then the scab would fall off and you'd be left with a scar.
Well,
what if instead of taking the fluid from a cow,
I inoculated,
he inoculated me,
let's say,
and waited until I had the lesion at the right stage,
then took some of my fluid and gave it to Brian and Nate and Murtala and spread
it through the community around me.
Then we don't need to count anymore because you could,
you could pass it from one person to another and passed the immunity from one
person to another.
And that works.
The problem with it is that,
uh,
you also can spread other diseases in that way.
You're not only spreading the infection,
but if,
but if I happen to have some other infectious disease,
then not only would you be passing the protection to smallpox,
but you'd be passing that disease among,
among the population as well.
And it turned out that another,
uh,
not quite as deadly but,
but still very serious disease called syphilis was also common in this part of
the world at that time.
And so you could,
you could pass diseases like syphilis from one individual to another and that's
not great.
Right?
That's not,
not,
not perfect.
The other problem is that as it was passed from me to another individual to
another individual,
then the vaccine could change in some ways that were hard to predict because
what accumulates in the lesion on my arm,
my is different in some way.
Then what accumulates in the lesion on a cow?
And as you move through the human population,
the,
the kind of response that you get could change because of the virus itself
mutates or because you're also passing on some factors that provide some
protection.
Uh,
that changes the course of disease and the in the,
in the recipient.
And so as the vaccine was passed from arm to arm,
it became less potent and him and the length of protection that it would give
you varied.
So if you were someone that was getting it after it had been passed through many
people,
you wouldn't have as strong or as lengthy a protection as um,
as the first individual did.
And we're going to just keep that in mind.
We're going to talk about the reasons for that as we go along,
particularly at the beginning of class next time.
But what was really needed in order to do this was a defined preparation,
right?
We,
what you would like to give is everybody in the community exactly the same
preparation so that you could predict what everybody's response to the vaccine
would be.
It wasn't until,
uh,
until the 20th century,
so almost 200 years later that,
that we learned how to do this.
And it was,
um,
it was based on a couple of things.
One was a better understanding of what you were doing when you vaccinated.
And I've already given you some clues about this and that this process of
vaccination that gender had developed was intentionally injecting into healthy
patients.
A micro organism,
in this case,
the virus,
the virus vaccine,
Ia,
which causes a serious disease in cows.
But only a mild disease in people
and injecting that,
uh,
because it was similar to very ola or the smallpox causing virus in some way so
that your immune system would develop a response to Vac Sinia.
But because of the similarity of the viruses,
the immune response that people developed would also protect them against
natural affections with very ola.
And so we call that now that process of infecting with a live virus that
produces an immune response that cross reacts with another,
uh,
that's called a naturally occurring attenuated vaccine naturally occurring
because we took a virus that occurred in nature attenuated because it causes an
immune response in people,
but a mild form of disease,
not the full form of disease.
And so this is an example of a naturally occurring attenuated vaccine.
Uh,
so how could you produce,
the question is how could you produce large quantities of this,
of this microorganism,
this,
this virus vaccine,
IA under controlled conditions.
Now,
you know,
because we talked about cell culture already,
that,
that a great,
that that we talked about last week,
manufacturing of cells we talked about two weeks ago,
that if you had a population of cells,
you could grow those population of cells and you can make,
if they adapt to the culture properly,
you can make an infinite number of sales from one starting solution.
Well,
if you knew a cell that could serve as a host for a virus,
you could use this process of cell culture to make large quantities of virus,
right?
You just grow up cells until you've got a lot of sales and you infect them with
the virus and you let the cells in culture produce the virus.
Well,
it turns out that we could not identify at least at that point,
a cell culture that would serve as a host for,
for,
uh,
vaccinium.
So cell culture production wasn't an option.
The only way that we knew how to grow it reliably was to grow it in its natural
host cows.
And so in the 1940s,
uh,
a group of people led by,
led by Collier started to develop a large scale production method for making a
reliable source of Vaccina virus.
And they did that by intentionally infecting cabs,
by harvesting their skin when they were at a certain point of the disease and by
isolating the virus from the skin of the cab cabs.
Okay.
And of course,
you could imagine that this took some time to develop and you'd want to make
sure that you separated the virus from all the other parts of cow skin so that
your ultimate preparation was enriched in the virus and didn't contain
quantities of other things that would be a hazardous.
And so that's what was done in the 1940s.
And then they found that they could freeze dry this preparation of virus and
freeze drying to lower the temperature,
freeze it,
then extract that all the water.
So you're left with a powder,
basically a powdered form of the virus that could be shipped all over the world
and then reconstitute it by adding water to it.
Right?
So it's like,
uh,
it's like,
um,
it's like Koolaid,
but,
uh,
um,
more potent,
but use the same way,
right?
The powder you could ship anywhere and reconstitute it on site and then it gets
injected.
And they also developed a very reliable way for introducing the virus so that
when they had a defined preparation of virus,
then you want to make sure that everybody gets it in their skin in the right
way.
And so they developed this bifurcated tool,
which would be,
you put the,
the,
the stuff on the surface of the tool and then you'd scratch the skin in a
certain way so that you could produce sort of a,
a,
a reproducible introduction of the,
uh,
of the vaccine into the skin.
Yeah.
Availability of this freeze dried vaccine made it then possible to think about
vaccinating people all over the world.
And,
and,
uh,
so it didn't take long once this vaccine where was available for people to,
want to get organized
and think about ways of delivering this vaccine to all the regions of the world
where people were potentially infected.
And it was the World Health Organization or who,
which led this effort.
And the,
the goal was to eradicate the virus,
to,
to get rid of it so that there were no natural sources of the virus on the
planet.
And that was possible in,
in smallpox because of a few characteristics of the disease.
One is that it's a,
it's a,
it's a purely a human disease.
Humans are,
the only,
are the only organisms that are affected by it.
And that's important,
right?
Because if it was a,
if it was a disease that was carried by both humans and squirrels,
for example,
then in order to get rid of it on the planet,
you'd have to vaccinate not only all the people,
but all the squirrels,
right?
Otherwise you could have,
you could have a squirrel host.
And I'm using squirrels cause I think that's funnier than other animals to think
of.
But it could be any,
any potential host.
Right.
But it,
and it would be really difficult to vaccinate a,
uh,
a wildlife.
So there were no nonhuman reservoirs.
There were no asymptomatic carriers.
So if you've got infected with smallpox,
you got the,
there weren't people that got infected,
like you can get infected with hepatitis B or tuberculosis and not even know
you're infected.
You might not have any symptoms.
You might just be,
have a latent source of the,
of the microorganisms somewhere in your body.
And that didn't happen with smallpox.
And that's important too because you need to be able to tell if,
if the virus is present in the human population.
And so because of those two things,
you could think about eradicating the virus.
And they did this very systematically by giving quantities of the vaccine to
countries all over the world.
That's part of it,
right?
Give enough of the vaccine.
So you have a dose for every body in the world or a large fraction of the people
will think about in sec in section how you don't need to vaccinate everybody,
right?
You just need to vaccinate a critical number in order to stop the disease from
progressing through a community.
And we'll think about that in section on Thursday.
But uh,
so you needed enough doses.
But this is,
this is real.
This is a lot of people,
right?
So you need hundreds of millions of doses at least,
and you,
um,
need a way to distribute that around the world.
And you need a way to keep track of who got sick and who didn't after they got
vaccinated.
So you needed some way of reporting.
And the WHO had all those had that whole infrastructure in place.
So they kept track of country by country when cases of smallpox occurred.
And as it was eliminated from regions of the country,
they then certified those regions to be smallpox free.
And so it went through the years from the 1950s through the 1970s,
the last reported case of smallpox in the naturally occurring smallpox was in
1977 a man in Somalia was infected.
There were no reported cases after that.
And so by the late seventies,
uh,
the world was certified sort of free of smallpox,
a world wide.
The U S was certified free.
Uh,
uh,
in the early seventies years before that,
I was born.
Before 1970,
I got a smallpox vaccination.
None of you got smallpox vaccinations because once a country was certified to be
small,
[inaudible] free,
there was no reason to,
uh,
there was no reason to vaccinate people,
any longer.
So,
so none of you in this room,
I'm,
I'm a hundred percent confident ever,
ever got a smallpox vaccine.
Uh,
well,
um,
that,
that's a great story and it's an an is example of a great success in,
in,
uh,
medicine.
Um,
but it's also an example of a great success in,
in,
in biomedical engineering.
And the engineering part of that is sort of the,
the part that I,
that I talked about in one slide,
but I talked about how do you convert this scientific advance into something
that can be delivered all over the world.
And the,
the,
uh,
um,
the technology that was used in this case was growing the vaccine in a natural
source,
harvesting it,
figuring out how to produce a preparation that could be distributed,
but with still biologically active that is still a could protect against the
disease.
We now know,
and I'm going to talk about next time,
lots of ways to do this,
alternatives to this method of bioengineering.
Ah,
and you could guess what those,
what those techniques are.
We,
you could use cell culture so you don't have to grow the virus naturally and
animals,
uh,
but you can grow it in cultured cells.
And the advantages of that are that that you can do this under very reproducible
conditions,
much easier to keep a flask of cells under very sterile,
very reproducible conditions than it is to keep a small animal,
right?
Even a or a large animal like a cow and much easier to purify and know what you
have at the end,
uh,
than if you're trying to harvest it from a,
from a whole complex organism.
We have techniques of recombinant DNA and those can be used to produce either
modified viruses.
We'll talk about that.
So maybe I could take an info,
maybe I could,
instead of getting lucky like we did in smallpox and finding a naturally
occurring organism that causes an attenuated form of the disease,
maybe we could genetically engineer a virus to make it less and less pathogenic,
right?
But still immunogenic,
And those words mean different things.
Immunogenic means that it stimulates your immune system for response.
Pathogenic means that it causes the disease.
So maybe you could figure out how to use what we know about molecular biology to
engineer a new virus that's still immunogenic but not pathogenic any longer.
And that's,
that's a new approach,
uh,
to,
um,
uh,
to producing vaccines.
Or maybe you don't need the whole virus.
Maybe you don't need the whole virus,
but you could just use a piece of the virus,
right?
Just use a piece and antigenic piece of the virus.
And then I don't have to produce the whole virus in order to make a vaccine.
I just have to produce many,
many copies of a piece of the virus,
a protein say.
And how would you produce a protein in large quantities?
But again,
you could use recombinant DNA technology,
get a gene,
put it in a plasmid,
get that plasmid expressed in a host,
could even be a bacterial host,
right?
Like we talked about with insulin and make large quantities of this recombinant
viral protein and use that as a vaccine.
And we're going to talk about how that,
how that,
how those steps can happen next time I want to end with this,
uh,
with this picture.
So this is a,
this is the,
the cover of the New England Journal of Medicine,
one of the most famous and influential medical journals in the world.
And this is from April of 2002 and I talked about eradicating smallpox in 1977
right when officially with the last case was reported and it was certified to be
eradicated shortly after that.
But I'm on this,
uh,
cover.
Uh,
you can see that there are several stories about a smallpox,
uh,
one is called the clinical responses to undiluted and diluted smallpox vaccine.
One is called a current concepts,
diagnosis and management of smallpox.
Why would,
why would one of the most prominent and influential medical journals in the
world be publishing a review article about how to manage cases of smallpox when
there had not been any cases of smallpox for 25 years?
Yeah.
So the,
the concern at this time and still remains a concern is that,
is that,
uh,
infectious agents,
particularly very deadly infectious agents like smallpox could be weaponized in
some way or converted into a weapon.
And if smallpox with somehow introduced into a city like New York City,
uh,
what would happen?
Well,
there's,
there's a whole population of people who are younger than me that never got
smallpox vaccines,
right?
You don't have it.
You don't have any immunity to smallpox.
You don't have any reason to have immunity to smallpox.
Uh,
and so you would be susceptible to infection by this organism in addition,
even people I got vaccinated 40 years ago,
right?
Is My vaccines still protective?
Probably not.
And so even people that got vaccinated,
most of us either have questionable or no protection against the virus at this
point.
And who,
where would,
if,
if it was,
if it was converted into a weapon,
where would the vaccines to protect the rest of the country come from?
There's no company that's making smallpox vaccine anymore because there's no
reason to make smallpox vaccine because nobody would buy it.
Right.
Cause there's no naturally occurring smallpox.
And so there was great concern that we were vulnerable in this way because the,
the,
uh,
the disease is still a disease that could affect people.
There are still,
there are still some,
um,
some active,
a smallpox virus specimens kept in the world.
And um,
and there are two sources of small or two places where smallpox is stored.
Now.
One is in the u s at the Centers for disease control where there is a sample of,
of uh,
very ola,
which is kept,
you know,
frozen on ice in a heavily guarded facility.
And there's another sample which is in,
uh,
in,
in Russia,
part of the former Soviet Union,
uh,
where there are samples that were stored and these samples are used for
scientific purposes,
um,
there,
and they are kept track of very closely.
But because there's still s smallpox that exists on the planet,
there is some concern that that could be obtained and used,
uh,
to develop a weapon.
So that's,
that's the reason for it.
Shortly after this.
And why did that come up 2002 because of what happened in 2001 is why that
became a concern there.
The government after this time did,
uh,
did issue contracts to manufacturing companies to produce new quantities of the
virus.
They also found some stockpiles of the virus from the 1950s that they still had
on an army base in Maryland,
I think.
And they tested those to see if they were still active and they were.
And so there's been an active effort to,
uh,
to reestablish a,
a,
the,
the process of smallpox vaccination in case that's needed.
And there are even some military personnel now who get immunized against
smallpox in the event that when they're going into areas they might be,
they might be exposed when they're in a combat areas.
And so I,
I give you this example to say,
even though tremendous progress was made,
and this is one example that without fail people would say is a marvel of
medicine.
And uh,
and,
uh,
bioengineering,
that,
that it's still something to keep track of.
And there are still opportunities,
uh,
to use what we know about this to develop even better methods.
I think the smallpox vaccine we ne we made now,
we'd probably be better,
more effective,
uh,
and uh,
and a safer,
uh,
than the vaccines we made in the fifties.
So I'm going to continue talking about vaccines on Thursday in particular,
we're going to focus at the beginning on polio virus,
which is another great success story,
but we're a very different approach to vaccine development was used.
And that will be instructive in thinking about what vaccines in the future might
look like.
Questions?
Great.
See you on Thursday.